you think you could have done it
differently without having to go through
all that pain yes and no so I don't
think that suffering is a requisite for
success but I do think that it is very
likely I think that a lot of times it
just reveals our character it doesn't
necessarily create it it might have
already been there that whole time and
then we just get the environment in
which to prove it to ourselves but I
think it goes from the man with the
opinion to the man with the experience
which Ellie Hardwick said no man with an
experience is ever at the mercy of a man
with an opinion so like there's some
soul hardness that I think comes through
that because you have evidence in your
past of like I have been through worse